let's talk about uh public sector pay
should we um and the minimum wage ahead
of the budget
tomorrow um hello paul scully is here
with us the business minister hello t
thanks for joining us on the program
it's always great to see you um rishi
sunix said oh last november i think i'm
writing saying that he couldn't justify
a public sector pay increase what has
changed in the last 12 months i think
we've um you know it's given us the gap
to uh allow for public sector finances
to or public finances to be looked at in
the in the hole now we've got a better
picture of where we are in terms of the
recovery having put 352 billion pounds
worth of
support into protecting jobs and
livelihoods he now has a better picture
to look forward and make sure that
having had the public sector pay gone up
previously
ahead of private sector pay it started
to equalise and now he can give all of
us public sector workers who do an
amazing job at pay rise how much well
that will be determined by the pay
review body so we each um the nurses
have their pay review bodies police etc
they each have their individual pay
review
bodies who will report back to him but i
think what it does take notice of those
do you well it gives them it gives them
a signal it gives them a signal that the
chancellor is you know is keen to give
people rise so they will then take that
into account as they look for um to what
um should be an appropriate rise for
public sector
given the the public finances as well
they can report back and the chance you
don't always take notice of what they
say do you we we tend to we try to
we try to but
it's a it's a review body we look to to
that to them to provide us evidence and
then we'll make our decision but we tend
to keep as aligned as possible but as i
say the chancellor has signaled that
very clearly and so when we will look
favorably when the pay review bodies are
reported make sure we get that paid rise
let's look at it in a different way then
inflation could hit four percent this
year so they're going to get at least
that
i think it's well i can't tell you
because as i say that's exactly
otherwise it's a pickup well that's
that's what the paper review bodies will
do i mean i can't preempt what they're
going to do i can't pretend what the
chancellor is going to say said now is
the time to give them a pay rise
and inflation could hit four percent so
unless it's more than four percent it's
a pay cut well i think as i say we will
see where we are come next april when
the review bodies have
paid what we've done though in the uh
reported what we've done in the um just
yesterday the chancellor and the
treasury were announcing the national
living wage increase of 6.6
so i think that is a a generous but
balanced approach to the lowest paid in
out um in in our society to to make sure
that businesses can still recover but
it's not balanced but it doesn't come
anywhere near uh the cuts uh in
universal credit of a thousand pounds
it's a gross increase of a thousand
pounds a year and what and
what we're doing is six percent six
would that depends on the circumstance
of the person well let me help you out
ifs paul johnson director of says it's
about 250 quid it depends on how many
hours those people are working so it's
it's you know he's made he's made one
assumption he's made one assumption but
but it will literally depend on some
people maybe part-time on that some
people full time something and how many
hours people it'll be 250. nonetheless
it's uh it's what you've got to look at
six point six percent is something that
that
it continues our um reach to making sure
that the national living wage by 2024 is
two thirds of um of average median wage
so ending low pay but not stifling the
growth and the recovery of businesses
that are paying that living wage um
because we want to make sure as i said
we can balance it between employers
and those workers that really need that
money you're talking about um businesses
let's look at business rates then um
should we where are we as far as that is
concerned tinkering around the edges
again is is what uh i read an article
this morning in business leader saying
um that
10 15 000 um
outlets have uh gone and uh tens of
thousands of jobs have been lost
directly as a result of you not sorting
out business rates i'm not sure whether
tinkering around comes so you have to
wait for the fundamental business rates
review which has been taken to be taken
into account
four times already well it's due to
report this all this autumn um
definitely well
that is again sits with treasury so
we'll see what the chancellor says on
wednesday if he has any indication about
that but i'm the hospitality minister
and the retail minister so clearly i
hear from those businesses who are on
the high street who are most affected by
business rates about their concerns
which are reflective to treasury but
others say the word is fundamental we do
know that uh business rates needs to uh
adapt to the 21st century to make sure
that we get the balance right between
high street um bricks and mortar and
online online shops and that will be
taken okay so just to clarify um it's
been battered away four times you still
can't tell me whether it's going to be
looked at this autumn
inflation is going to be 4 but you can't
tell me whether a pay rise is going to
be more than that for public sector
workers and uh as far as universal
credit is concerned that was a thousand
pounds that's been cut and some people
might only get 250 uh despite the
national living wage is that what we're
saying well look let's take that last
one the universe okay fine but i can go
through it through all of them you know
pay review as as i said the bodies need
to report before we before we um uh but
it could be a pay cut you acknowledge
that it could be a payment it could be
anything
well it could be anything we need to see
what the pay review bodies say what it
could literally literally couldn't be
it's the pay review bodies four percent
what inflation is going to be unless
it's higher than four percent is going
to be first first of all you're making
the assumption about inflation let's see
where we get to that event
needs to be higher than four we're also
making a review
we'll also make an assumption on what
the pay review bodies to say let's see
what the pay reviews bodies are saying
but what the chancellor has done he's
indicated that he wants to make sure
that he can give but unless
the rate of inflation
is not very good at maths but i've
figured that one out yeah but you're but
this is all speculation what i'm saying
is that okay let's not say four percent
and let's say whatever the rate of
inflation is unless the pay review body
comes in with higher it's going to be a
pay cut isn't it so well that's just
basic math but we'll let's see but as
long as you've got let's just see what
the pay-per-view okay
let's talk again about the national
living wage then because um as i said
the director of the ifs paul johnson
says that to some people uh the new
figures will mean that they're taking
home an extra 250 pounds um and they're
losing a thousand pounds with universal
credit so that's also a pay cut but you
are again first of all you're only
taking one thing there because for the
people that are i talked about the fact
that 200 pounds depends on
what 250 pounds depends on what their
circumstances are how many hours there
will be you acknowledge that some people
will be impressed but then on top of
that for the lowest paid we have the
household um fund that was announced by
the chancellor that's um uh that is
being
delivered by local authorities to those
most that need we have the energy price
cap we have the increased uh free child
care allowances that we've built up over
the last uh the last few years all of
these things
have a suite of measures to help the
people most in need so just taking that
one emergency uh measure the universal
um uh uplift that that cutter
that came to the end or as the emergency
started
to recede when it's reversed basically
but nonetheless as i say that was then
replaced by a 500 million pound
household fund to target it to target it
at those most in need because we've
talked about the fact that the national
so you're saying that people are going
to be better off next year what i'm
saying
what i'm saying is that we are
increasing but for the most vulnerable
the lowest paid in society um their
living wage by 6.6 what we don't want to
do is build a recovery based on the
backs of those people uh that are lowest
paid in our society so getting that
balance right to make sure that we don't
stifle the recovery by um by choking um
uh business are you saying people are
going to be better off next year what
i'm saying is that they're going to get
six point six percent payments well i
can't make those assumptions in terms of
inflation and other costs at this at
this moment in time what i am going to
say is that pay packets are going to go
up by six point percent six percent if
they're on the national living wage at
the moment okay um the uh
the leader of the house of commons um
the speaker i should say uh very cross
with the chancellor saying what about
all these leads in the budget why am i
not hearing about this in the chamber
for the first time tomorrow yeah well
i'm sure the the the chancellor will
answer that but i think it's important
that we um that people know these uh the
these um concerns have chance to digest
them to debate them to
um to talk about them um over the last
few days as they clearly have you're
casting out for people's opinion
no
what i'm saying is that um you know i
think it's important for people like
yourself to actually be able to discuss
that with me this is the way we're going
to do it
well i'm not the chancellor so i don't
know it's the honest answer do you think
it's a good idea i'm just telling i
think having the discussion about these
sort of things making sure that um the
people on the national living wage for
example don't miss out on seeing some of
the detail because it's lost in a
massive budget document oh i'm sure they
don't know if they're struggling with
the payback absolutely are they i'm sure
they're going to i'm sure
they will also see some of the other
things they will see some of the other
things that are available to them as
well that sometimes get lost will you be
wearing a mask for the budget
i'm not sure if i'm in the chamber for
the budget if you are but i but it
depends on how crowded it is it's going
to be packed yeah in the in that case
which my wire might not be in the
chamber because i've got and if you are
and it's packaged if it's absolutely
where i have been in a um
a room or an area where it has been
absolutely rammed then i wear a mask i
wear a mask in the cab on the way here i
wear a mask on the tube on the trains
because all your colleagues don't tend
to or many of your colleagues don't tend
to do they i think the signal look the
signal needs for people to um you know
we've been locked down for 18 months and
government have been telling people what
to do for 18 months what we have said to
people now use your common sense use
your own initiatives um make your own
informed decisions we know that we're
living with covid um and so that this
doesn't just suddenly go away overnight
so it's really important that uh we
allow people to make those make those
informed decisions and be respectful for
other people as well around them it's
gonna be look a bit weird isn't it when
all the labour benches have all got
their masks on and lots of the tory
benches don't
sending a mixed message isn't it to the
public as usual i think that i think the
message is that as i say make your
decisions for yourselves okay but you
access accept that it's mixed messages
if half the house has got masks on the
other well look it depends where you
want to go to if you want the government
to be dictating to you every minute of
the day that's one thing is it a mixed
message
it's it's a message that you can use
your own decision
you use your own initiative use your own
make your own decisions good to talk to
you thanks so much indeed for joining us
on the programme